hello and welcome to the playing Scott
from Italy it seems so let's see what I
can do in this Italian game okay the d3
line so who is solid choice like as many
possible and set up against this slow
kind of build up this is just one of
them okay no egos t4 interesting i can
just do this and claim that it didn't
really help him that much that he played
d3 d4 in two loops okay so huh not quite
sure where to put the piece of CM i add
seems that he wants to play Bishop to be
one know this and bishop to be one
Jim and no okay I can do a c4 in this
position but I'm not sure that it is
helping that much yeah it doesn't
doesn't do all that much okay so let's
just get out of the sea file here and
gap before doesn't really help me here
at all it opens up the the bishop the d3
bishop hmm well it's not not that easy
here to find a good continuation hmm
okay let's try this one for Bishop b5
next bit unsure about this but it looks
like um interesting option at least
maybe I have c4 come okay I ok wants to
go e 6 in this position and hmm that's a
bit of a problem
I wonder if roop the age as a move in if
he takes one have six route III somehow
that looks dangerous for me but if I
don't do that he will play e6 and
damaged my pawn structure enormously
this somehow looks like it does not work
many who yeah he's got 95 coming up this
is the problem the play look every now
he will take g7 the service this is a
thing
and 95 yeah I didn't consider this yeah
I cannot move the rook 96 would be
killing the problem is after Bishop
takes I'm in a self purnia he will go
queen well somewhere and so mad I mean
is seldom inner self pin see if I can
actually just take
I am covering the roof so that the
bishop can move yeah I wonder if c4 is
some mafia I mean I have to try
something I cannot just stay just hang
around do nothing
can I go Bishop c5 here I age six hangs
thanks
I'm just blundering the bishop what am I
doing here what I know I'm really
playing very strange chess at the moment
him a route d3 buddy I can just take the
bloody bishop oh my god ah how did this
position wasn't that clear may be
objectively lost it's not even taking it
it's not even taking it time morning
nary it's still lost but it would have
just taken this piece and I lost maybe
not not lost but pretty bad
do some threatening bishops is seven
year it's a very crude threat
yeah even that move works
just hoping for some kind of blunder
here ignite h5 the bishop h2o you never
know somehow is not finishing me off Ian
hmm not sure what this is doing huh
maybe this is making it easy if I'm I
don't know if i get f 6 somehow this
isn't this isn't so easy
it's just really one time yet very like
a check rook h5 I would have got that
covered white forfeits on time I don't
know what's what was happening in this
game very weird yeah so I think here we
have a pretty normal position which
should be should be roughly equal I mean
I don't think as much going on yet this
is maybe not a good idea I'm yeah II
five is strong I just didn't see six
just currently my feet is really off for
the game and this is a yeah this is bad
because 95 is hitting me so hard if I
now move the rookie will just take g6 I
was thinking but I have this move
actually so it wasn't all that bad I
should just play here I mean maybe he
can the end it wants to do this
yeah it's very worrisome some sacrifices
here engine gives y plus one and I mean
I'm not one hundred percent convinced
because if it doesn't have any sacrifice
and it shouldn't be in that bad shape
but it feels pretty awful okay but I
gave a big change and probably am in
trouble now look ed one was stronger a
lot stronger yeah this is fluttering the
bishop of course yeah this is what the
engine wants to play and it gives white
just plus plus 0.6 so it does not feel
all that clear
this is the engine slow in check yeah I
mean something like that is better for
white but there's always some hope would
like to maybe being able to haul it not
fun not fun yeah by then I just played
this move and then he took like you just
didn't take it I mean there's absolutely
nothing here what did we had game oh and
here I i missed Bishop c7 yeah thnkx
with chick so he has to go back check
and now yeah well yeah I'm okay the
computer gives equal very very very good
position actually go to pawn and the
bishop pair thats it's really okay okay
I didn't I don't see anything here the
moment and he took like a minute for the
small I know maybe something happened on
his end you never know yet but now it
was pretty clear that I was winning on
time he overstepped the time very very
strange game I'm barely played by me but
I was lucky at the end okay well thanks
for watching